[Musica]
tutti noi siamo abituati a pensare che
per essere se stessi andare all'anima
livello che siamo sia necessario rompere
degli schemi
e se invece vi dicessi che in realtà
sarebbe sufficiente andare all'origine
della parola schema
è una domanda
la parola schema
deriva dalla radice sanscrita sac che
significa sostenere prendere saldo da
cui deriva il greco schema tous che
significa forma pertanto originariamente
lo schema è la forma che sostiene che
rende saldo quella che oggi definiremmo
la sostanza all anima di qualcosa di
qualcuno
se pensiamo però all'uso che tutti noi
quotidianamente facciamo della parola
schema ci appare evidente quanto il
significato che andiamo attribuirgli sia
fondamentalmente diverso perché quando
ci riferiamo a degli schemi ci riferiamo
generalmente ad e modelli a degli
scheletri a un insieme di regole
universali che valgono per tutti e che
prescindono da chi e da cosa abbiamo di
fronte
vi faccio un esempio
io un bambino di 9 anni
stasera non è qui perché mi ha detto che
aveva di meglio da fare
e quando le voglio farla studiare
che so i sumeri nico fatti uno schema
ma quando gli dico di farsi uno schema
non gli sto dicendo di andare all'anima
di chi ha di fronte di capire chi erano
veramente sumeri
quando gli dico di farci uno schema il
suo chiedendo implicitamente di
semplificare di sfrondare di spogliare
di ricondurre tutto a un modello
magari sarà lo stesso modello che lui
utilizzerà anche per studiare greci
romani e così via
attenzione perché qui la differenza è
sottile
io gli sto insegnando
a trattare cose diverse ma soprattutto
persone diverse secondo l'unico stesso
disegno noto
che penso che lui potrà riconoscere e
quindi gestire meglio
adesso il paragone vi ho fatto che
sembrava un po azzardato e vi posso
assicurare che nella mia esperienza di
persona che ha ricoperto diversi ruoli
in altrettante aziende multinazionali e
non questo è esattamente quello che
succede all'interno delle grandi
organizzazioni
perchè in queste strutture nelle nostre
aziende si fa un uso concettualmente
sbagliato e la parola schema per queste
aziende
schematizzare significa spogliare
sfogliare ogni individuo delle sue
unicità e delle sue caratteristiche per
renderlo uno scheletro uguale altri
mille e per questo più facilmente
gestibile secondo regole universali
io penso che ognuno di voi da dipendente
abbia avuto almeno una volta nella sua
carriera un'idea un'intuizione geniale
un genio creativo qualcosa di brillante
qualcosa avrebbe fatto la differenza ma
che avrebbe comportato un cambiamento
e sono convinto che di fronte a questo
cambiamento vi sarete sentiti dire molte
volte quella fastidiosissima frase qui
abbiamo sempre fatto così
sono anche convinto che se siete stati
manager vi sarete ritrovati a pregare
almeno una volta che quel tipo in gamba
si ma un po strano
no vi desse troppo fastidio e vi sarete
impegnate a sfondarla di tutte quelle
che erano le sue caratteristiche quelle
che lo rendevano veramente unico e
cercare di omologarlo a tutti gli altri
la mia esperienza e credo anche quella
di molti di voi
ci dice e ci suggerisce che queste cose
succedono quotidianamente e che sono
alla base della mancanza di motivazione
da parte dei dipendenti della mancanza
di leadership da parte dei manager e
definitiva per tutti della mancanza di
quella marcia in più che
produce risultati straordinari
ognuno di noi nel corso della propria
carriera professionale indipendentemente
dal ruolo si trova almeno una volta a
dover fare una scelta
quella di lasciare l'azienda in cui
lavora
cedendo il proprio posto al prossimo
scheletro
oppure quella di rimanerci in quell
azienda
rinunciando però al 50 per cento delle
proprie potenzialità e diventando
progressivamente ma lentamente un altro
tipo di scheletro
ora adesso
cerchiamo di riflettere c'è una cosa che
non facciamo molto speso fermiamoci a
pensare a cosa succederebbe invece
se andassimo all'origine della parola
schema
immaginate cosa succederebbe se ogni
singolo manager
andasse all'anima di ogni singola
persona
invece di tentare di farne una pedina di
cui deve necessariamente poter prevedere
ogni singola mossa
tra lo so nelle nelle nostre realtà
aziendale è uno sforzo di immaginazione
particolarmente elevato però vi starete
chiedendo se è successo
se questa cosa è possibile se c'è
qualcuno che ha mai avuto il coraggio di
farlo
e allora mi piacerebbe raccontarvi una
storia
una storia una bella storia che risale a
un po di tempo i fan non è la mia perché
non era ancora
siamo in america
siamo in california
nei primi anni 70 più precisamente si
ammassa nivel che ha una cittadina nella
baia di san francisco
a sunnyvale vive nolan che un giovane
ingegnere che nel 1972 fonda sari
una delle prime aziende al mondo nel
settore videogiochi
a tali si distingue da tutte le altre
aziende per due cose una è il prodotto
che fa e l'altro è il come lo fa e tutte
e due queste cose sono fortemente legata
alla personalità di nolan
nolan era convinto che alla base
dell'efficienza produttiva
ci fosse la totale libertà d'espressione
e che questa fosse un prerequisito
fondamentale
in ogni processo che implichi implichi
complicasse
creatività un mix di creatività e di
ingegno
per questo è stato inventore della
settimana corta dello smart working e di
tutto quello che oggi chiameremmo più in
generale flessibilità strumenti di
flessibilità lui aveva capito che non
potevano esistere regole uguali per
tutti e che tutti non potessero trarre
lo stesso tipo di giovamento ricevendo
lo stesso tipo di trattamento
lui aveva capito evidentemente prima di
molti altri
che i problemi in azienda quelli veri
nascono quando iniziamo a trattare le
persone come tanti scheletri e non come
tante anime una diversa dall'altra
questo manager innovativo aveva creato
un ambiente in cui ogni singola persona
potesse esprimersi per quelle che erano
le sue caratteristiche
e per capire qual era ancora queste
caratteristiche
usava degli stratagemmi e adesso
definiremo geniali abbiamo parlato prima
della settimana corta
bene in affari e venerdì pomeriggio si
organizzavano delle feste
feste a base di pizza birra e
videogiochi doveva sembrargli sensato
che lo dicevamo interiori
e durante queste feste nolan aveva
l'occasione di girare fra i suoi alle
sue persone in un ambiente assolutamente
informale e rilassato
poteva capire quelle che erano le
dinamiche che intercorrevano fra i vari
team di lavoro e ne approfittava per
fare delle domande informali alle sue
persone perché è degli hobby e passioni
propensioni caratteristiche
e invitava anche dei potenziali
candidati
per fargli conoscere l'azienda per
fargli conoscere potenziali colleghi ma
soprattutto anche qui per fargli delle
domande extra curriculari domande le cui
risposte non sarebbero potute venire
fuori durante un colloquio formale
tra l'altro le feste del venerdì sera
erano tutto fuorché improduttive perché
qui le persone abbiamo detto si
parlavano cosa si parlavano e
interagiranno tra loro
giocavano
sviluppavano nuove idee e progetti il
primo gioco multiplayer della storia o
uno dei primi
è stato inventato proprio in occasione
di questa di queste circostanze
dalla necessità di otto dipendenti di
lavorare di lavorare di giocare in
contemporanea dove lavoravano anche
però non facciamo l'errore di pensare
che
anche un manager
lungimirante innovativo come nolan non
abbia avuto i suoi momenti di crisi
momenti che capitano a tutti nella vita
tutti noi momento in cui ci guardiamo
davanti allo specchio e ci chiediamo
mettiamo in discussione i nostri valori
ai nostri principi ci chiediamo se
quello che abbiamo fatto fino al giorno
prima
adesso è veramente la pena
ha avuto anche lui momento in cui si è
trovato spalle al muro
rischiando di diventare uno dei tanti
manager di quelli che conosciamo di
quelli che vanno sullo scheletro e non
all'anima delle persone
e uno di questi momenti
e stato quando alla sua porta a bussola
giovane steve
steve era un ragazzo di 18 anni col
passato abbastanza complicato piuttosto
pesante nella porta della società
i suoi veri genitori l'avevano data
un'adozione una coppia di sunnyvale con
la promessa che loro lo facessero
studiare
suo padre ad attivare un meccanico di
auto e suonare una contabile
maschile quando si presentò in affari
non era scelto il modello di cambiato
ideale perché a parte che aveva lasciato
quel college che college per cui era
stato adottato
poi era vestito da hippy
e era già passata l'era degli hippy e
si presentò alla reception di atari
dicendo che non se ne sarebbe andato
daily fino a che qualcuno non avesse
assunto
quindi l'assistente di nolan si fece si
fece due risate e chiamò giusto che per
forma chiamo nolan e gli dice cosa gli
chiese cosa dovesse fare con quel
ragazzo se chiamare la polizia scelta
per lui fortemente consigliata o
piuttosto farlo entrare e non lo hanno
ovviamente lo fa centrale ma quando
steve si è presentato davanti a nolan
era maleodorante trasandato e non dava
l'impressione di aver capito bene cosa
volesse dire il verbo socializzare
però non l'hanno noto tutto questo nolan
si sofferma sul suo sguardo su quello
sguardo acuto attento fungente uno
sguardo che secondo lui doveva
mascherare un tipo diverso di
intelligenza un tipo particolare di
intelligenza e allora su due piedi senza
pensarci molto prese lo assunse per un
periodo di prova
bene a quella si sarebbe rivelata a
breve una delle scelte sbagliate che non
l'hanno avesse mai prese la sua vita
fino a quel momento
perché si viva fin dal giorno dopo
cominciò a creare problemi
non andava d'accordo con i colleghi
faceva scherzi di cattivo gusto
e dopo qualche giorno diventa quello
quello giovane quello nuovo quello
sporco quell'odioso quello che non
sapeva niente dell'elettronica
tutti tenevano emarginarlo e lui ma non
faceva niente in realtà affinché questo
non succedesse anzi lui alla fine
pur non avendo esperienza si riteneva
molto più intelligente degli altri e
quindi non sentiva prova necessità di
interagire con i propri colleghi però
immaginate come in una azienda di 40
persone che questo possa costituire un
grosso problema
immaginate anche come nola si trovò ben
presto affrontare una scelta
se licenziare quel ragazzo preservando
la pace sociale in affari oppure se è
continuare a seguire il suo istinto e
tenerlo però creando il malcontento in
tutti gli altri
manola non fece nè l'uno nè l'altro ebbe
dei giorni di crisi ma poi preso una
decisione
e
si ricordò e andò
all'origine della parola schema si
aggrappò quella forma che sostiene rende
saldo e si concentra sull'anima
sull'anima di steve su questo sguardo
acuto e pungente quello che secondo lui
nascondevano intelligenza particolare e
lo fece nel rispetto di tutti gli altri
perché si inventò di punto in bianco un
turno notturno che non era mai esistito
in atari un turno in cui avrebbe potuto
far lavorare e steve
ai progetti in cui si stesso credeva di
più che tra l'altro coincidevano nei
progetti in cui tutti gli altri di
affari non credo e con quella soluzione
che oggi definiremmo assolutamente fuori
dagli schemi ma che in realtà era
assolutamente dentro il significato
etimologico della parola schema
nolan sia sicuro una delle
collaborazioni più prolifiche della
storia di affari una collaborazione che
dette luogo e la nascita un gioco molto
popolare per quelli della mia
generazione che si chiama black out e
che contribuì in maniera molto
significativa a fare di atari quell
azienda multimedia d'aria che è arrivata
fino ai giorni nostri
ma io non vi ho raccontato questa storia
solo perché nolan sia stato uno dei
pochi manager lungimiranti della storia
o un manager che abbia avuto un coraggio
di fare delle scelte alternative
io vi ho raccontato questa storia anche
e soprattutto perché se lui nel 1974 non
avesse fatto proprio quel tipo di scelta
noi ci saremmo persi il talento di quel
ragazzino
e molto probabilmente anzi sicuramente
ci saremo persi questo
[Applauso]
nolan bushnell
fondatore di affari e steve jobs
fondatore di apple sono due persone
hanno avuto il coraggio di seguire il
proprio istinto e proprio intuito
sono due persone che hanno avuto il
coraggio di essere se stessi di portare
avanti quelle che erano le loro idee e
di rimanere coerenti con quello che
erano non fermandosi allo scheletro ma
scendendo in fondo fino all'anima e
questo evidentemente li ha premiati
in quel celebre discorso alla stanford
university
steve jobs ha pronunciato quelle parole
che hanno fatto il giro del mondo
siate affamati siate folli e stasera se
mi permettete vorrei aggiungere qualcosa
in più
indipendentemente da quello che fate da
chi siete che siate manager o dipendenti
mirata alla vostra essenza
punta fallani ma vostra e soprattutto a
quella di chi vi sta di fronte
perché lì e solo lì che abita il vero
talento
grazie
[Applauso]